[Applause]
personal bing vision
sometimes champions people are back in
action and marine leather
finally reforms well that is to say from taiwan
ago goods and goods
dead space ship and night in the air
out span span span
visions campani bondage and rho
technology and his referred
technology and bass both will join off
[Laughter]
who can tell you and the walls bucks
is a dog and it was the right mix of pat
hughes
smart browns of hanif atmar
moroccan outsiders
but ricotta and a circle I start with
me comes from outside  of a self-respecting ipad
in piazza brin in serie b explorer 6 ie6
action history of now cleaner turn
clean energy one new man of action
but what kind of hardware and experts chosen
by frank gehry making betfair
friendster spikes from outside without open
space
so our systems  on the science of
you see the day
compared to 66 and expert of like [ __ ]
that we of an amazing clara
no sense and furniture
[Applause]